this is why I left La there was a
business in Burbank that got taken away
from the owners because they stayed open
during the second lockdown of covet
their electricity was turned off the
business was boarded up chained up
multiple times and then it became
personal for the owner the whole
Community rallying behind him he would
break through the doors every time he
would open it back up Community donated
generators they kept shutting down
electricity and the kicker for me was
there was one last at the council
meeting with public comment and what it
looks like was going to happen was that
they would have to shut down for two
weeks pay the fine to they had accrued
and then open back up because at this
point every other business in La was
open except for this one except for this
one the City of Burbank sent out a
construction crew and they built a wall
around the business a 10-foot barbed
wire and I was like
so I'm living in a place where the
government can literally come in and
take your home take your business
because they disagree with something
that you've done